aoc warning democrats are in huge
trouble this november if the party
doesn't move further to the radical left
quote if the president does pursue and
start to govern decisively using
executive action and other tools at his
disposal i think we're in the game but
if we decide to just kind of sit back
for the rest of the year and not change
people's lives yeah i do think we're in
trouble so i don't think that it's set
in stone i think that we can determine
our destiny here
and the media thinks democrats have a
serious problem when it comes to
messaging
what this poll essentially tells the
president and democrats is that they
have to be messaging better
that they have to be talking about the
things that americans are listing as
their priority 38 of americans are
blaming biden's policies um for
inflation and gas prices and only six
percent are blaming russia remember that
president biden wanted to call this
putin's price hike
all right dana 30 of americans are
blaming biden and uh very six percent
blaming russia is it a messaging problem
that the hashtag doesn't work i mean you
got to really come up with something
else well i for one completely agree
with alexandria ocasio-cortez and i
think that all the republicans out there
would gladly
contribute to her hotel and airfare to
have her travel all around the country
and say these very same things i do
think president biden set himself up for
this right so he catered to the left he
wanted their attention he's
for a long time remember he wanted that
build back better bill and he told them
that they he would they would get it and
they played along for a while and now
they are mad and i would like to tattoo
this on my face
from the time biden's american rescue
plan passed to today
inflation has consistently run ahead of
wages delivering a substantial pay cut
to all americans and everyone knows it
and it doesn't matter what kind of
hashtag you put on it this is what
they're going to deal with and this is
why they have such bad numbers but i
absolutely agree with aoc okay all right
jesse they're talking about an
enthusiasm gap uh on the part of
young people and on a part of the
democrats that we know that young people
generally vote in a presidential year so
they can't count on them this year what
enthusiasm can they gin up for this
election well there's no boogeyman
there's no trump and there's no policy
accomplishment to get behind so i don't
know you'd have to ask them i mean let
me just put my mind
i'm a 29 year old radical democrat okay
i'm bisexual
i wear an n95 mask in the shower all my
friends move to
austin texas so i'm lonely
and inflation is killing me
and
i don't know i i'm i'm probably hurting
pretty bad and it financially i'm worse
off than i am
you know before the election so they
really don't have anything to run on do
you remember judge when you were in
middle school you did the trust falls at
those little
you retreats up and you fall and someone
has to catch you and it's supposed to
establish trust that's what the left did
with biden and biden dropped them he
didn't deliver anything that they wanted
and now they're scrambling and figuring
out wait i didn't get student loans i
didn't get green nintendo what did we
get we didn't even get election reform
so aoc is upset so she's threatening the
president but she's also upset because
this will be the first time aoc is not
in power in washington she got swept in
after 2018 she's been in the majority
all these years she's not going to have
subpoena power she's got no juice so
she's looking at a little bit of a
lonely time oh very good point all right
what do you think about what happens if
the democrats lose the house what should
the republicans plan to do well here's
the thing i'm going to be a wet snuggie
and say that the party out of power
always gets seats right they always make
significant gains so if you get 20 seats
in one senate seat
don't pat yourself on the back you lost
because this is a tremendous opportunity
right now you have the locust most
progressive people spouting off if
you're just normal republicans if you're
just normal you've got to get at least
40 seats and win back the sam
uh senate or you're going to blow in my
opinion the best chance you ever had
because chances like this only come like
once every 10 000 years
according to science so just be normal
do not do stupid things don't fall into
their traps right they're going to try
to get you into culture wars and things
like that and try to drag you into like
race-based controversies just be above
it you know take the fight but but uh if
if the republicans don't get 45 seats
uh i'll be very disappointed all right
pierce what does it look like from where
you live in terms of what is happening
in the united states what do the brits
think well i just think if you were
thinking of how things could possibly
get worse for joe biden it would be to
embrace aoc with that annoying squeaky
voice which makes me want to feel like i
want to grate my head against a cheese
grater
i find it appealing whining might
improve my looks
[Laughter]
i think she's uniquely irritating and of
course she represents this ultra left
ultra work mentality you know it could
only get worse if you piled megan markel
in with her and the paradigm came up
biden and said you know you got to do it
our way um
he quite rightly sees the danger here
and it when it comes to the midterms i
think he's heading for a massive
shellacking as things stand but it's
really down to the economy and it can
only get worse for him if he embraces
anything that aoc is currently preaching
because that is the very mentality which
is i think
the minority in america and the vast
majority of people find it intensely
irritating so if i was biting i would
completely ignore her and i would try
and get a message which people actually
listen to about the economy and how
you're going to fix it because most
people that i'm talking to as i walk
around new york in the last week it's
that they're talking about they're
talking about the economy they're
talking about prices at the pump they're
talking about food prices and you add in
the ukraine war and the impact they that
may have on global food prices this is a
real ongoing economic crisis and at the
moment the guy in charge of this keeps
trying to blame vladimir putin but as
the polls show the american people blame
joe biden he's got to change that
message somehow before november it's got
a lot of work to do hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else